as much as this feels like the start of
this video I am very embarrassed to say
this but it sort of isn't I had to
exclude like one hour of recording of
this coaster because it went so damned
terrible i actually did go for the arrow
coaster in the end since it just fits in
the park more the park has more of a
classic right sort of feeling to it not
really the classic ride feeling that you
would have with for example the really
old wooden coasters with side friction
but you know we've got the oldest stuff
in here no B&M coasters or newer
high-tech rides and even though an arrow
mega looper is somewhat modern I do
still feel it feels more in place with
you and the rest of the more classic
things in this park but yeah I had so
much trouble designing this coaster
designing it really makes it sound like
doing some sort of tough thing it's just
a game but I as I had so much trouble
actually making this coaster since I had
to make it fit inside this this sort of
space that I had and it's very confined
I didn't even think a winged coaster
would fit in this space really and I
also wanted to make it look like it
would be a stereotypical standard arrow
mega looper but of course I didn't want
to rip off the layout of existing one so
it sort of had to clearly look like it
but yet not be it's at the same time
which was quite hard to figure it out as
well and I sort of started off with
these loops but in the end it was sort
of hard to get the corkscrews in
basically half of this is just me trying
to get the double cork screw because
there was no way that I couldn't get a
double cork screw into this ride and
actually make it work and go to the
station without colliding with any of
the existing coaster track it did
actually work there for a second but it
just felt way too close to the track
that I had over there so I don't know
what I went with exactly unlike my
thousandth try to see and get those
corkscrews in what I had to rearrange
every single part of the right multiple
times just to be able to sort of make
the finale work in the end which was
sort of tough but I suppose it's worth
it it's the sort of thing that I would
to have in the Pythons a clear where I
almost finished it at least it I'll go
nope nope there we have still don't
finish it so yeah this this took a while
this was a killer terrible IRL I was
watching my hand at these corkscrews
were way too long and usually I don't
have that much issues since especially
with this sort of coaster there's a
certain formula that you follow to make
it which makes building coasters a lot
easier and usually a lot quicker as well
but in this case I sort of found that
the formula was holding me back more
than it was allowing me to actually make
this a smooth ride literally and
figuratively which is sort of tough but
the rest of the park though I do have to
say this park is following like the
stereotypical formula of like the the
guide for potential theme park owners
especially in terms of roller coasters
we just have the standard kiddie roller
coaster and the family suspended go
through the very much necessary and
obligatory wouldn't go through and then
of course the big coaster with the
loop-de-loops which should be this one
in the end i don't think i went with
these corkscrews in the end either I'm
like trying to get it around that lifts
hill but then the loops were just in the
worst place ever oh this is how i did it
actually yeah there we go it is about
finished eventually after about it was
over two hours of me struggling to make
this thing actually look the way it does
but then it was alright I suppose though
I had to say the colors another problem
I sort of wanted to go with the standard
arrow mega looping mega looper colors
which is just rhetorics and white
supports but then again I already have a
red track coaster and I would feel bad
having two coasters with the same track
colors in one park especially that close
together and of course its way to
standard over color scheme for this
Costa type but the issue is I I want to
have some sort of color scheme that
looks dull enough to be an arrow goes
through that even makes sense you kinda
wanna have some more metallic colors and
sort of almost washed out since arrow
coasters are so all in the lab
did it and I didn't want it to be come
to gray at least wanted to be somewhat
bright since this is parka text and the
bright style just fitted a little bit
more I suppose also the screen just
froze for a second though which is
because i think i don't know what i did
there but one thing to kind of keep in
mind with these videos is that sometimes
the game crashes which is actually
something that i had here in there
surprisingly i think this was the first
episode where it crashed on me though
but it just randomly did and i mean it
is still pretty alpha build but I sort
of didn't expected and another thing is
that every time I leave the game it
actually pauses it which is something
that I don't have in roller coaster q3
and I might have mentioned this before
but sometimes I just want to close the
game for a couple of seconds to change
the song that I'm listening to or
something like that and whereas in rolla
cosec and three it still keeps on
playing in the background and it doesn't
awkwardly just freeze for a second this
game likes to just completely freeze
whenever I like I leave it to window
which is good in some sort of sense that
it doesn't do weird things while you're
doing other things but in the time lapse
sometimes it is almost like the the
video is buffering or doesn't work for a
second which if you do click on the
video because it's suddenly freezing
because I like to change my song or
something that I'm listening to I'm I'm
sorry about that but it just happens
sort of I mean I could I could not leave
the game and make this time-lapse a
little bit better but really in the end
I don't give a [ __ ] and I just want to
be comfortable playing this game so yeah
whatever this is a little bit of just
finishing the main street trying to make
this look somewhat Alpine but it's just
it's just impossible actually the better
way to make your parks look alpine
probably is to just make your buildings
a lot larger and make them more Alpine
in shape since the idea that I sort of
went into when I tried making these
buildings is to have these very Austrian
Tyrolean sort of buildings we have these
awesome balconies in the front of it but
I'm just missing the very core
components
of them so even though they do look all
right in the end and it's a cute little
Main Street I suppose it just doesn't
really carry the atmosphere that I was
going for in a way and I really feel
like I shouldn't have done this and ty
lee it is always more Western than it is
alpine or at least it doesn't really
know what sort of theme it is it doesn't
mean that I completely hates the look of
this main streets but not knowing what
sort of theme it's supposed to be is
sort of how I feel about the way that it
looks it's sort of just there without
any sort of central idea these that's
how I feel about it there's actually
some funny things here and there though
this was a good park to practice with
especially for finding out different
users for different scenery objects just
to name a few really the sign which is I
think from Kenny signs and banners sets
can be used for pretty much anything in
the world really it can be used to just
decorate fences but it's also sort of a
little board underneath your windows
since I couldn't have the window boxes
underneath your windows I figured yeah
whatever is in this sign will have to do
as a funny little decoration there you
can use the posts as chimneys for
buildings which are kind of annoying to
get the rights placement of since you
don't really have the grid for them if
you want them in the middle of your roof
but then again the they do look some
what's convincing as chimneys I do kind
of like them as much of a pain as it is
to place them and it's just those little
things that I kind of kind of come about
when playing the game as the same thing
is over here if you used those western
facade pieces you can actually get some
wooden framework onto your walls as long
as you keep the same color of the wall
and the same color of the posts you can
just combine any sort of war peace with
little accents on its to create entirely
new accent decorations which is a lot of
fun too and actually open the game up to
try and build a city which is something
that I haven't even shared yet and it is
actually pretty good for that the art
style
do you think it would even fits some
sort of city management game but overall
you already have a lot of freedom over
what sorts of buildings you can make in
this game it's definitely missing glass
pieces but other than that you can
actually make really funny buildings
with this you may say that sort of video
in the near future I might actually
start a very short series about a city
but really I'm messing with too many
things in this game and it's all very
random and on a whim hand I shouldn't
make videos of that I'm not even too
sure about the future of making videos
of this game what I should do with it
but I'll probably just start another
park after this one which should be a
bit more organized and less like a
random practice park to kind of get the
hang of things which is honestly what
this park was for a great deal not to
say that I'm not happy with how this
Pike turn out because it's always there
just need to finish the foliage and
these stations of the the invert and the
arrow maggot looper and some simple
paths stuff but i think it's it's time
for a change and also some more practice
in any case that's the end of this video
so thank you for watching and I'll see
you guys in the next one